the only sentence that he has there is
colorless green ideas sleep furiously
and what's interesting about is it's
syntactically well formed but it's
semantically anomalous you can't have a
colorless green thing you can't have a
green idea you can't have an idea that
sleeps and you can't sleep furiously
right so it doesn't really make sense
piano didosi is impressed you shouldn't
be impressed that I said it because
people have been talking about this for
50 years it's in Bartlett's quotation is
chomsky's most well-known sentence those
have the same syntax as the first
sentence but if you scan them and you
look at them they're not chomsky's
sentence the whole point of chomsky's
sentence is that these things are not
things you can have an image overdue in
real life there's nothing wrong with a
purple fluffy Cloud it is not capturing
what Chomsky said and yet pantadosi is
saying this system understands what
Chomsky did Gary do you think Steven's
scoring a known goal because the
language model that's scoring a known a
known goal that means when you put the
football into your own goal oh yeah yeah
that's right it's a cell phone it's a
cell phone exactly